okay hi there welcome to another episode
of
science and technology q a for kids and
others
and i see we have all kinds of
questions here
uh let's see
where should we start well there's a
question from
uh travel here why does silver farms
consume
so much power and what advances are
possible with parallel computing to
reduce the power consumption or get more
computations
with the same power okay
so why does computation take
energy it's a good question
and actually it doesn't need to
there are so what happens in a
in a computation you might be saying
there are uh there's a uh
there there's a piece of my program
which says
if this is true if if this thing is a
one
and this thing is a one then the result
is a one otherwise it's a zero
that would be an and gate that's a
that's a particular
uh thing that exists on on a
microprocessor
that would be a particular operation
that could be performed by a
microprocessor
and the question is why does doing that
actually take energy
and in the present day
the the reason well that is
i'm realizing it's a slightly
complicated question to answer
the um there is a
in order to kind of push the electrons
through the so these ones and zeros and
so on they're represented by clumps of
electrons
in order to kind of push the electrons
to the place you want
to be able to do these computations you
have to put energy into pushing these
electrons to go to the right place
now there's a question of why
can't you set it up like you would in
like a mechanical system if you had
sort of perfect billiard balls the
billiard balls bounce off each other
and there's they don't they the um
the energy that you put in is kind of uh
regained when the billiard balls go to a
different place
and so it's um so
it is possible to have sort of processes
that happen
that don't sort of use up energy
um as as they run and so it was it was
for a long time it was thought that
when you do computation you necessarily
have to use energy
it became clear by about the 1970s that
this wasn't the case
that it was possible to do reversible
computation
see see what happens when when you kind
of push those electrons through
to to get results from the computation
you're ending up
turning some of the energy that you put
into pushing those electrons through
into heat heat is sort of random motion
of atoms
and once energy has been turned into
heat
it's hard to get it back again into
something more systematic that you can
use
so so the traditional way of doing
computation
involved pushing electrons around and
some of the energy that was used to do
that pushing
would end up as heat actually part of
the reason for that
is is the following so imagine that you
have
a um imagine you're rolling a ball
you have a ball that's that's going into
some bowl or something you have a marble
that's going into a bowl the marble is
is going to the marble goes in the
marble
runs down one side and the marble might
just run up the other side
the reason it doesn't run so far up the
other side
is because of friction because it's
losing energy if it was
the energy that it has the potential
energy it has from being a certain
height on one side of the bowl
it will use up that potential energy
turning into kinetic energy of motion
when it gets to the bottom then it will
be able to turn that
kinetic energy of motion back into
potential energy and climb up the other
side of the bowl
so it will be just if there was no
friction
the marble would just be oscillating
back and forth back and forth across
the different different uh sides of the
bowl but because of friction
the thing will eventually lose energy
and come to rest at the bottom of the
bowl what is friction
friction in the end is the conversion of
of mechanical processes of motion
into just heat it's it's something where
you're taking sort of the the motion of
the marble
and you're you're just making things
heating things up and you're you're
taking that systematic motion of atoms
and it's being turned into kind of
random motion of atoms that corresponds
to heat
okay so people thought that if you want
to get a definite answer from a computer
when it works out that and computation
for example
they thought you needed something like
that idea of friction
to get it to come to a definite answer
they thought that
if there wasn't something like friction
it would be like oh i think the answer
is this i think it's that i think it's
this i think it's that it would never
come to a definite answer
that to get it to come to a definite
answer would need to
have something like friction which would
dissipate heat which means that
you put energy in and you don't get
anything out from it you just get heat
out from it
that was what people thought now it
turns out that isn't true
turns out that it is possible to make a
computer that is completely reversible
and you can do it conceptually by just
imagining that your computer
is made from a bunch of perfect billiard
balls that are perfectly elastic that
just bounce off each other
and with the exact right pattern of
billiard balls you can do whatever
computation you want it turns out well
so this
idea of reversible computing is
theoretically possible
um it's never actually been done in
practice
practical computers right now still use
the fact that kind of you have to
you have to have some sort of friction
you have to you have to dissipate heat
to get the thing to come out with a
definite answer and
the question is how fast do you want the
thing to come out with a definite answer
well the the more you can
have the the faster you can push the
electrons effectively
and the more you can just allow that
pushing to turn into heat
the faster you can get an answer now in
practice and the design of
microprocessors and so on
that turns into questions about
capacitance and
and uh uses of of uh
voltages and and uh
sort of details about about the way that
you're
sort of charging up capacitors and
letting them uncharge and so on let's
not get into that doesn't
so it's it's more details of the
electrical engineering um
but uh the the main point is
that the the the more energy you put in
more or less the faster you can get
things to run
given that there is a certain
uh degree of sort of physical character
to these electrical signals and all this
kind of thing
so the reason that servers tend to use
lots of power
is your you know the kind of the harder
you push them
the um uh the the faster they'll go
now there are details so
for example in the detailed design of
microprocessors
there are trade-offs about how exactly
you'll set up the wires
whether you'll have these these sort of
talk between wires when that happens
uh whether you'll have um uh
certain features of of the way that the
characteristics of the individual
components work and so on
and by tweaking the engineering you can
end up with using less power
um because things sort of just go more
smoothly
in terms of the way that the the
underlying physics of of the
of the devices is set up and sometimes
by
by
letting the thing run slower you can use
less power but so
typical server farms have this trade-off
between
how much how fast they go how much power
they use exactly what design
does the thing have and sometimes when
people have really redesigned
microprocessors from the ground up
it's been possible to design them to
work with lower power so for example in
the
in the whole sort of story between intel
and arm
two different major microprocessor
design
design companies um there's sort of been
been issues for example there was uh for
a while the issue that sort of arm had
in
simpler designs not as sophisticated as
intel's designs
but those designs were sort of created
from the ground up and it was possible
to make lower power versions of them
which is why arm processors one of the
reasons arm processors became popular in
cell phones
because that was a place where power was
at a premium whereas in servers
it's like the thing is connected to the
electrical grid and you can just put
power through it and get computation
done
in terms of of whether things like
parallel processing
will help with the sort of the power
that's used in service
probably not so much because once
when you're computing you're computing
you're doing it in parallel you don't
sequentially doesn't really make much
difference
you know i know for my computers they
have many cores in them
and you start to when if you start
running a program
that is making use of many
parallel cores so normally when you run
a program
in the simplest way of setting up a
program the program has a series of
instructions in it
and those instructions get executed in
series
and so on your computer there's just one
the
the the computer is just saying i'm at
this point in the program okay i'm going
to move the program counter to another
point in the program
then another point it's sequential but
in modern computers there are often
multiple cores
multiple different uh pieces of of
microprocessor that can separately run
programs
and so it's it's pretty common to want
different programs to run in different
cores and for example your operating
system and your computer
will be running the different programs
you're running in lots of different
cores
on your computer but sometimes you have
a single program
where you want to divide up the work
into multiple cores let's say for
example
you're going to process a whole
collection of photographs and you're
going to
i don't know you're going to turn every
uh
um every cat in every photograph green
or something you want to go through and
you want to use some machine learning
algorithm
to turn every cat and every photograph
green and you've got a million
photographs
how are you going to do it well you can
have a sequential program
that just opens each photograph does its
thing
and you know decide turns the cat green
saves the file again goes on to the next
one goes on to the next one
but let's say your computer has i don't
know
uh 20 cores or eight cores or four cores
that it makes more sense to have those
separate cores
each separately go out and deal with
their group of photographs and do all
those things in parallel
but when you do that and when each core
is doing some sort of computation
intensive thing
you'll often hear your computer start to
make more of a noise what's actually
happening what's happening is
the cpu is all those different pieces of
the cpu all those different
cores are starting to be used and the
computer is using more power
and it has a fan typically that is or
many computers have fans
that are kind of blowing air across the
top of the cpu chips to keep them cool
um
because they're using more power and so
they're going to heat up and what
happens is
usually there's a certain operating
temperature range of temperatures for
for microprocessors
it's determined by the fact that if you
make the electrons in the microprocessor
too hot if you make the microprocessor
if you take make the semiconductor that
the microprocessor is made out of
too hot the electrons will start kind of
moving around in the material
even in ways that you sort of didn't
tell them to move around by putting
voltages on and so on
so there's usually a a maximum
temperature at which a semiconductor
device can operate
and so you have to if you're starting to
put more power into this device
you have to be pulling power out by
having by blowing air across it
and having sort of heat exchange happen
and so on and so that's why
when when you're making your computer do
more work the fan will start
up as it's trying to blow air across
that microprocessor
to keep it cool so that it doesn't go to
a temperature that's too high
that um uh uh
that that where it switches off you know
i i discovered once i
i remember when was i thinking when i
first had an ipad a very very long time
ago
when ipads first came out i i left the
ipad
on a um on a dash in a car
it was a sunny day and this ipad because
it had
effectively a black screen when it was
switched off was just absorbing sunlight
like crazy
and it got really hot and i was kind of
impressed that when i tried to switch
the thing on
it came up with this warning thing
saying this ipad is too hot
it will damage itself if it switches
itself on you know let it cool down
before it can before it can be operated
and that was
that was a microprocessor that had
gotten outside of its
normal operating temperature so that's
why why these things have to be cooled
in in elaborate ways and so if you go
into a
you know in a typical if um if you go
into a server room
uh server farm for example they're
usually called they're often called
server farms
um i'm not sure that's a good comment on
the way that animals are
kept in some kinds of farms but because
they're just rows of servers
um that uh are just doing computations
and so on
and a typical server room we set up in
so-called hot aisles and cold aisles
so you have all these rows of servers
and they're they're all stacked up
they're usually
the the pizza box form factor is a
pretty common one
where the the actual computer is the
shape of a pizza box basically
and uh uh it's it's fairly thin
sometimes they call blades
um the uh where the the circuit boards
for the computer are just lie
horizontally
and um uh you you're stacking them all
up to make this big
big um uh big server uh big big
configuration of server room
and usually what will happen is there's
a side of it
that's cold where where it's being
cooled by the by the
uh air conditioning and the server room
and then there's a back of it that's hot
uh where it'll just be blowing out waste
heat
from the operation of the server and
that's sort of a typical setup and it's
often the case
that the amount of computation that can
be done the number of servers you can
put
in a server room is limited by the by
the rate at which you can get heat out
of the server room
um and uh that's and so sometimes people
do
crazy things like they they have uh uh
they try and have several rooms sort of
embedded in glaciers
or there was a there was a trend at one
point of having you know underwater
servers
um that were uh kind of dissipating heat
uh to an ocean there's a there's a more
amusing
version of that which is if you have
um for example high altitude drones
that um for example are providing things
like cell phone service
you can do computation in a high
altitude drone where it's getting power
from sunlight and so on
and because it's really cold at 60 000
feet or wherever the drone is operating
you don't have to have the kind of
cooling that you need to have
in a server room the drone can just as
it's flying through the air
and it has a server on it the server
will just be cooled by the
by the low temperature of the air at the
altitude that the thing is flying at and
so you can
you can kind of optimize things in terms
of cooling but in terms of what will the
future be
in terms of uh power consumption of
computers my impression is that
the engineering progressively gets
better and it's progressively possible
to sort of
remove all those little uh stray things
that
that that use more power than they
should
it will take some new technologies i
suspect to dramatically reduce the
amount of power that's consumed
and certainly some of the technologies
that people use for what they imagine to
be quantum computers even if they're not
really quantum computers operating
really really according to
to the laws of quantum mechanics some of
those technologies
particularly ones with optical with
light and so on instead of
electrons instead of electricity some of
those
will likely lead to things that are
computations that take a lot less power
um so that's a a comment um uh about
that
um let's see
the questions here
boy um
[Music]
okay there's a question from aaron here
have you ever had ever had a situation
where uuids collided and caused some
sort of issue
well that makes me talk about what uuids
are
um i've sometimes said when the uuids
collide the universe will
end um i say that somewhat uh
somewhat facetiously but let me explain
what uuids are
and uh and and and how this works so
uuid stands for universally unique
identifier so let's say
that you are going to you have a whole
network of computers
and uh somebody you're going to have
a uh a file that's created on one of
those computers
and you want to make sure that that file
is named in a completely unique way
so even though you didn't check with any
of the other computers
oh do you have a file named this do you
have a file named that you want to make
sure that the name you come up with for
that file
is going to be universally unique that
no other
computer will come up with that same
name
you might also do this if you were for
example if you were
generating addresses for
little devices and you you're going to
have a trillion devices in the world
and you want each of them to have a
unique address one way you can guarantee
that they all have unique addresses is
to have a registry
where you're listing all those addresses
and you check for every new device you
add
is that address i'm trying to add in the
registry or not
if it's in the registry i can't use it
if it isn't in the registry i can use it
but the point of a uuid is to avoid
doing that
to use the fact that if you have a
long enough number and you pick it
randomly the chances are
that that will never be picked at any
other time so in other words
if you were to say i'm only going to
i've got a thousand possible
ids that i can use well
if you by the time you've got maybe
about 500
different um uh different things where
you're picking the ids
the chances are you'll have a collision
with chances are two things will both
randomly get picked as id number 205 or
something
and then whatever system you had that
relied on the fact that no
two different things ever have the same
id will just get
get uh will fail so the idea of the uuid
is um that you have something
where it's a long enough randomly enough
picked number
that the chances are it will never be
picked the same
two name number will never be picked
ever again
in the sort of history of the world and
typical uids are these days what is it
256 bits i guess
um so they are they're usually written
out
in hexadecimal um so hexadecimal is base
16
we usually use base 10 and so in
hexadecimal
they're numbers 0 through 9 and then
there's a number there's an a
for 10 b for 11 etc up to f
so those are the digits of hexadecimal
and usually uuids are numbers that are
written out in hexadecimal that's the
most common way they're presented
but they're fundamentally just numbers
but they're numbers
between uh 0 and 2 to the power 256
minus 1 and those numbers that's the
typical choice of uuids
that that number is big enough that it's
for example
larger than the number of atoms in the
universe so the
if you were to number uh if you were to
use the uuid to label every atom in the
universe
there's a good chance that if you picked
that label at random
that every atom would get a different
label so
that sort of seems enough that the uuids
aren't going to collide
um and the question is
to make sure that uuids don't collide
you have to pick them at random
if you say every tuesday i'm going to
pick uuids of this form
well that's bad news because then the
chances are you'll end up picking two
identical uids
it's the same kind of problem as if
you're trying to pick a password a key
for a cryptography system you want to
pick it sufficiently randomly
that that that same key won't ever be
picked again or that people won't be
able to guess what you picked
um so there's sort of a challenge of how
do you make
how do you pick the uuid randomly enough
that it won't that the same thing won't
get picked again
it's not that difficult in practice to
do that so
i've never seen a case where uuids
collided so many systems in the world
today depend on uuids not colliding
that i have no idea what would happen
it's a good kind of doomsday scenario
to figure out what happens if the uuids
collide
i don't know i think a lot of things
which where
the identity of a thing is determined by
uuids
would get very confused and people where
they think they're two different users
of a computer system it would be like
oops the uids have collided they're
actually the same user
and that would get very confusing and
things where only one user is supposed
to have permission to see something well
actually another user
with the colliding uuid will get
permission to see it and so on
a lot of things would go crazy in the
world so we have to sort of hope that
uh that you ids won't collide and we can
know that
so long as they're picked randomly
enough they won't collide i might tell a
piece of history that some of you may
know some of you may not know
about kind of things people assume about
computer systems and what goes wrong
with them
this is about the y2k problem and this
is supposed to be a
q a for for kids and others so the kids
may not know about the y2k problem the
others
may know about the y2k problem what
happened is
uh heading for the year 2000 there was a
big sort of panic
about the way that computers stored
dates
because computers are typically stored
year month day
and the way they'd stored as a date and
the month they store as you know zero
eight or something for august the day
they store as
you know one five for the fifteenth of
the month and it's like
uh programmers had thought well let's
just store the year as two digits
it's all good that was the decision that
was made in the 1960s
and it's like let's store the year 1998
as 98
let's store et cetera et cetera et
cetera use just two digits
well the problem is that a lot of
programs said
is this date after that date and so they
would say
uh we compare the dates so first we
compare the years
is this year after this year okay well
you know the year 1998 stored as nine
eight is correctly identified as being
after seven
five which means the year 1975.
but if you're storing things only with
two digits
by the time you get to the year 2000
it's
that doesn't work anymore the year 2000
is after the year 1999
but zero zero the number zero zero
is before the number nine nine so the
sorting of dates we got wrong
so people really started to panic a few
years before the yi2k
year 2000 uh moment of oh my gosh
all the computer systems in the world
are going to fail and so
a bunch of companies that sold sort of
systems that deal with particular
transactions and databases and things
they were like this is the most
fantastic opportunity we've ever had
we can finally get people to upgrade
these systems they've had the same
system for 20 years they've never been
upgrading it
you know it's going to fail you know
let's not patch the thing let's just
have the thing fail and say the only way
you get to have a system that works
when y2k happens is to have a new system
so it's
a huge amount of activity in sort of
patching up computer systems so that
they didn't fail
at the moment where where y2k happened
people really thought
that there might be a possibility you
know the the air traffic control system
would fail the nuclear power stations
would fail
the electrical grid would fail that that
at that moment
where the uh where y2k happened the
world would end
it's kind of like the uh the mayan
calendar which has this feature that it
eventually wraps around and people sort
of
wonder if the world is going to end
where the calendar wraps around
people were really wondering what was
going to happen at that moment
when the the the beginning of the year
2000
uh when two digit dates uh would have
failed in that way and i remember
we had done a lot of stuff at our
company to try and be ready for y2k
some of it was probably overdone
actually because there was such a sort
of generated panic about y2k
and i remember at the at the uh at the
moment where y2k happened i was like
uh you know let me send a piece of mail
to all people the company you know happy
new millennium type thing
and uh let's let's get that right at the
moment of y2k
and let's see if anything actually fails
well it didn't um
actually interestingly enough there's
another y2k like problem
in the year 2038 that's coming because
uh in unix common operating system
common sort of foundational operating
system
for many computers there is a
uh it's often the way that unix stores
times is our seconds after the year 19
after january first 1970
and it turns out that the number of
seconds after january 1st 1970
by the year 2038 will be more than the
number of bits that you can store in a
32-bit word
um and so that if for systems that have
32-bit
uh that use 32-bit numbers there'll be a
sort of y2k like problem in the year
2038.
i don't think it's going to be very
serious because everybody will move to
64-bit systems
and uh i think um uh the sun will no
longer be shining
when um when 64-bit systems ran out of
seconds
so it's uh so we don't have to be too
concerned about that
um all right it's a question here about
um uh i think coming back to servers and
things like that
um from reem why does bitcoin use so
much power
uh
let's see well
all right basic point
what is bitcoin bitcoin is a
cryptocurrency
that is based on the idea of blockchain
what is blockchain blockchain
is a way of recording transactions it's
a way of having
this chain of recordings of transactions
where
it's set up so nobody can fake it it's
set up so that
you you will have you store this person
paid this person such and such a number
of bitcoin
this person paid this person and if
somebody says i've got this bitcoin i
can pay you
somebody can go back the system can go
back and automatically check
is it really true that you still have
that bitcoin or did you already spend it
and so there's this ledger there's that
goes all the way back to when when
bitcoin was first uh deployed in what
1998
am i getting my years wrong around that
time
is that right um that uh has it been
that long
no no no and maybe i'm i'm off by 10
years maybe it's 2008.
um in any case when um
yeah i think it's i'm off by 10 years
there um
so when bitcoin was first deployed the
first transactions were recorded
on the bitcoin blockchain and
transactions have been being recorded on
that blockchain ever since
and the way it works is there are maybe
10 000 maybe 20 000 copies
of the bitcoin blockchain and different
on different people's computers all over
the world
and all those copies are consistent and
so when somebody says
do you really have the right to give me
this bitcoin you can go
check any of those copies of the
blockchain and you can make sure that
yes
that bitcoin hasn't been spent it's good
you can go ahead and give it to me
type thing okay so the question then is
how does though how do you decide
when a transaction happens how do you
decide that that was a valid transaction
that really happened
and it should add it to the ledger of
transactions to this blockchain
of possible transactions and there are a
variety of different schemes but the one
that was picked for bitcoin
was a thing called proof of work and
sort of the idea is
people can
oh let's see how deep do i want to go
into this people
the the notion is you have to decide
who is going to add the next block to
the blockchain
for bitcoin a block is being added about
every 10 minutes these days
and what's happening is within each
block there'll be this whole big list of
maybe i don't know a thousand
transactions
that happened that are being recorded on
the blockchain for all time
and the question is in order to put that
block onto the blockchain
you have to make certain cryptographic
things connect with the previous parts
of the blockchain there has to be sort
of a valid
way that you add that block to the
blockchain but
the question is who gets to add that
block and
you want to be the person adding that
block because
every transaction that's in that block
being added to the blockchain
comes with a certain commission and if
you get to add that block
you get to take all those commissions
you get to be paid in bitcoin
all of those commissions and so so you
want to be the person who adds the next
block to the bitcoin to the blockchain
question is how is it decided between
these 10 20
000 uh different uh places where the
blockchain is stored these different
who's going to add the next block okay
so
in order to add a block the rules of
bitcoin are such
that you have to solve a particular
essentially computational puzzle
and the puzzle is basically there's all
of the data
that corresponds to a sort of a hash
code
hash codes are you take some collection
of data
and you kind of mash it up and you get a
number out of it and
so you might have a huge amount of data
and you mash up that data
you just get this number that's a 100
digit number let's say
and uh hash codes are useful because the
chances are
two different kinds of data that you
mashed up will end up with two
with different 100 digit numbers so if
you want to find out whether these two
things are the same
you just compare their hash codes and
that will tell you well sort of an abuse
of the idea of hash codes
is what happens in in bitcoin because
what's happening there
is one's asking can you find a way to
take all the data
that exists on the blockchain plus a
little extra piece it's called the nonce
and to arrange the nonce so that
when you take all the all the data on
the blockchain plus the nonce
that the hash of all of that is a number
of exactly a certain form
that uh starts with a bunch of zeros
okay
so the the problem of blockchain is
that the way you decide who gets to add
the next block
is who's the first person who picks the
nonce
to get the hash that has the right
number of zeros at the beginning
i forget how many it is now maybe 14
zeros i think it's got to now
um and and the difficulty of finding
that hash
is being made more difficult every few
years as
you're required to find a hash which has
even more zeros at the beginning
so so what's being done bitcoin mining
is the process of trying to find those
nonces effectively
that will generate a hash that has the
right number of zeros
now so and and to do that
the only way people know to do that is
you just try a lot of hashes
you just try and try a lot of monsters
and you see what the hashes are
and suddenly if you try enough of them
chances are you'll say ah i'm the winner
i've got the one that starts with a
bunch of zeros um
and so that process of bitcoin mining
that's what it involves and the the sort
of
concept is that these are so-called
cryptographic hashes
and they have the property there's
really no way you can find out
whether the hash will have the form you
want except by just running the hash and
seeing what happens
this is very related to this idea of
computational irreducibility
that i developed back in the 1980s and i
i think it's very likely that the
original
nature of bitcoin knew about that idea
and that was sort of
uh the origin of this notion that you
can have to do irreducible computational
work
to achieve something but so that the
idea is that
the so what's happening is uh people
have made all sorts of special purpose
computers and things
and they count the number of giga hashes
the number of billions of hashes
per second that those computers can do
to try to
find the find the nonce to find the you
know to add the
the um uh to add the next block
and so people um uh that that's some
um uh that that's so
so what's happening the the energy
that's being used in in mining bitcoin
is just running all these hashes to try
to see whether
you can get the one that is going to
allow you to validly add a block to
to the blockchain so this is an
incredible waste of electricity
it's a you know when i invented
computational reducibility i never
imagined i could never never imagine
anything like this
as a sort of application of
computational irreducibility why does it
make any sense
it makes sense because you want
something that is sort of hard to make
you don't want something that
doesn't take any commitment to make you
don't want something where everybody
just say
i'm i got the block i got the block i
got the block i have to have some way of
deciding
it's kind of like you imagine people
digging up gold
somebody is the person who gets to find
that gold deposit and go to all the
effort of mining it
and that's the person who gets that
piece of gold and it's the same kind of
idea here in
in in bitcoin and you know i think
people say that the
the total amount of electricity used in
bitcoin mining is comparable
to the electrical output of denmark and
it's it's predicted in a couple of years
it's going to be comparable to the
electrical output of italy
i don't know if this is all correct but
lots of uh lots of electricity
um is being used in bitcoin mining a
question you might ask
is could bitcoin mining be actually
solving a useful problem
instead of doing this kind of uh
computational puzzle
of solving hashes i have wondered about
this i've never figured out how to make
it
something where it's solving a useful
problem because you kind of have to know
in a sense you have to know the form of
the answer in order to validate
the fact you've got a correct proof of
work so to speak
so it's hard to have something where
it's doing something useful
where it doesn't know the answer though
as i'm thinking about it telling you
about this
i'm thinking about whether there's a way
to get something where there is an
answer and it gets to that answer but
there is an intermediate step that was
necessary to get to that answer and the
intermediate step is useful
the answer is known that the
intermediate step is useful
the other issue with computation that
are useful is
it may be more difficult to know for
certain just how difficult the
computation is expected to be
although the truth is that with
cryptographic hashing
it's a question of did you guess the
right thing by by good luck or not
um there are other approaches used in
other blockchains
the most popular is a is there are many
different ways
to decide who gets to add the next block
sort of another one that's becoming
popular is proof of stake
where you're basically showing that you
own a bunch of that cryptocurrency
and you get to sort of vote on what the
next block is that's a
that's a different way in fact ethereum
is just transitioning to something uh
close to that maybe it it's just
happening right now ethereum 2.0 i think
uses that kind of method rather than the
just burn computer time to
to uh to solve these uh these
computational problems
let's see there's a question here from
slayer very different kind of question
what is the correlation between sleep
and weight loss
boy i don't really know um i think a lot
of that
information is so deeply anecdotal i
mean i i
am uh it's always some
uh you know we don't really completely
know what the function of sleep is
people uh you know i've always assumed
that sleep
is necessary to clear kind of junk out
of the brain
much as when muscles get tired because
they build up lactic acid
from uh from sort of the repeated uh
um nerve uh
um the the the repeating of that um
um of the operation of the the the nerve
uh
on the muscle um that uh you know just
as one builds up sort of the waste
product of lactic acid
in muscles someone must be building up
some kind of waste product in the brain
as a result of having a sort of waking
day and i think people say adenosine is
one of the possible
things that is produced as a waste
product from the
uh the sort of electrical activity of
neurons in the brain and then
sleep is sort of a time to clean that
out and to their sleep
because of the way biology tends to work
once it has a capability
it's going to pile a lot of other pieces
of functionality
on top of that capability so it's like
okay given that you've got the animal
asleep
let's have it uh do this let's have it
do that let's have it uh you know have a
time when it's
digestion is doing this so when it's um
something else is doing that
and i think um the uh
so sleep ends up getting used for many
purposes even if it's primary purpose
might be sort of cleaning out gunk from
the brain
it's getting used for lots of different
things and some of those things probably
have to do with
some of the kinds of things that relate
to one's metabolism and so on
certainly one knows that you know
temperature goes down
at night heart rate goes down at night
um
i'm not sure how all of those uh things
play together
and i think the um a general finding
is people need a certain amount of sleep
um and if you don't get it bad things
happen
uh things like your immune system stops
working as well
you're more likely to you know catch a
uh catch a virus because your immune
system is not as aggressively
uh attacking it uh your uh
you know all sorts of different things
happen you you don't think as clearly
because
you know something is kind of um uh
gunking up your brain perhaps
but so there are different things that
happen when you um
uh don't have enough sleep and i think
it's one of the
the uh the things of modern times i
don't know what's happened to people's
sleep during this pandemic i
i kind of think it might have gotten
better that uh you know there's
people in many periods of life tend to
have a sort of chronic lack of sleep
where they're like well i've got lots of
things to do and then i gotta get up
very early in the morning and
and certainly uh school systems have had
a terrible habit
of getting kids to get up super early in
the morning even though
you know the way that we are all
synchronized you know we have this kind
of circadian rhythm
that tends to synchronize when it is
that we think we should sleep and it's
so
synchronized to the sun um and uh it
also tends to be aligned relative to the
sun and i think
people generally believe that
particularly kids are actually
quite unsuitable as teenagers and things
at least to be getting up super early in
the morning and it's kind of a crazy
thing
that uh that for example schools often
start very early in the morning
and i think that's been something
there's been some pressure against that
but it's something which sort of the
societal structure of things is such
that well it's really good to get the
kids off to school because then
the parents can go into work or whatever
um and so that's how that develops
but it's probably not the optimal thing
in terms of cognitive performance of the
kids and so on
but uh so i think um uh
so i don't know the answer to um uh the
relation to uh uh
to weight loss um
us aaron is pointing out that the number
of atoms in the universe
is actually larger than the size of a
256-bit uuid
you know as i was saying that i was
remembering that i i think i mentioned
this in this little book i wrote called
elementary introduction the world from
language
i think i discussed this question of
just how big is the typical uuid
and i i'm i'm remembering um uh
the um um uh this point you're
absolutely right
that the it wouldn't quite make it to
label all the atoms in the universe
um the question of how we know how many
atoms there are in the universe we know
how big the universe is
uh we know um they're um
uh let's see they're about some
uh yeah they're about a hundred billion
galaxies in our universe each one has
about 100 billion stars in it
each star has about 10 to the 57 atoms
in it
and so we we know from that uh roughly
how many atoms there are in the universe
um it's about 10 to the 80th
atoms in the universe that's a that's um
uh 10 times 10 times 10 times 10 80
times
so it's uh if we counted out a trillion
as 10 to the 12
so if we counted it out um uh let's see
can i do the math here
uh it's a a trillion trillion trillion
trillion trillion trillion trillion
trillion
uh atoms um in in the universe
which is quite a few but um and uh
and more as you are correctly pointing
out then you fit in a 256 bit uuid
so at the point uh which is not going to
happen in our universe with the
evolution of our universe
at the point in the in the very very
very distant future of our universe
um the uh
uh that you know when
when the time the universe the 14
billion years of our universe existed so
far
when that time looks like something
infinitesimal when the universe has
evolved
you know many many many orders of
magnitude more than that time
then maybe we will be at a point where
the uuids that we have today
will have sort of more serious problems
so to speak
um of course it's not clear there are
many other weird things that can happen
in the universe before you reach that
point
um
gosh okay all sorts of interesting
questions here there's one from mahmoud
how to convert black and white video to
color
so this is something people have been
doing in recent times you know you've
got a black and white movie
that was made in the early 1900s and
it's like let's colorize this
and the traditional way to do that is
people with paint brushes effectively
you take every single frame
and you go and you kind of change the
color of the
of the black and white areas in every
single frame that's a traditional way to
do it
um and you know by using human judgment
you say
uh you know this um
uh you know this cat was yellow type
thing
and let's just decide in this cartoon
that was made in
you know 19 you know
1925 or something let's just decide this
coat was red
and then we color all those frames in
the right way okay the thing that's
become possible recently is more
automated colorization
and the way that works is as follows
it's it's using machine learning and
using neural networks
and essentially here's the idea imagine
that you could show a computer examples
of
zillions and zillions of different
pictures maybe you could show 100
million pictures
and each of those pictures has things
that have certain shapes and certain
colors
you have a tree it's got green leaves on
it the tree is a certain shape
and the leaves are green you have the
sky it's
up there and it has it's sort of plain
and it's tends to be blue you have
different kinds of things and they tend
to be certain colors
so essentially what one wants to do is
to say given the shape
we can we know 100 million examples we
can look at the shapes in those examples
and we can say what color did a thing of
that shape happen to be
in that image and so then if we can
learn from those examples
we can say given this movie frame that
has a picture of this this and this in
it
we can reasonably guess based on the
examples from those hundred million
images
we can reasonably guess the sky up there
is blue the grass down there is green
et cetera et cetera et cetera and so the
kind of the
the idea of colorization automated
colorization is that idea that you learn
from all these examples
and then you implement it in the
particular case that you're showing
now how does that learning work and so
on that works
using these things called neural nets
which were kind of invented as a
as a idealization of what's happening in
our brains
and essentially what what goes on there
is that
well it's a fairly complicated story
altogether but roughly
you've got a program that has a lot of
different variables in it millions and
millions of variables
and what's happening is you're saying
you want to train this program
to follow certain examples so you might
show the picture
it says that's an elephant you say no
it's not it's a cat
and then and what it's doing then is it
setting those different numbers inside
the program
to be such that okay it said it was an
elephant but actually it should have
been a cat
so let's tweak those numbers to make it
say it's a cat in this particular case
show another picture it says uh you know
that's a car and you say no it's an
elephant
you tweak the the things a little bit
more to say okay make that be an
elephant as well
and you keep doing this tweaking and you
do it billions and billions of times
and after enough time you can have ended
up tweaking it to the point where it'll
more or less get things right
and it'll more or less say yes that
really is a cat in that picture
and so you can do the same thing with
colorization you're progressively
training using existing images
and you're getting it to the point where
you where it correctly says the grass is
green the sky is blue etc
and that's how this automated
colorization mechanism works and and you
can find in more from language for
example
we have some colorization uh neural nets
that will do this kind of automated
colorization
and it works fairly well it's not
perfect but it works fairly well
um and uh it certainly can bring some
black and white pictures somewhat to
life
there's a question from heather here how
much sleep do i get at night
you know i'm one of these people who who
knows a disgusting amount of information
about myself
and uh i have all that data the answer
is about seven hours usually
and um i i usually make sure that um
uh i kind of budget for eight and expect
to get seven
um and uh the um uh
and it's i think uh over time
i have probably needed a tiny bit less
sleep
um and uh it's kind of a feature of the
of the horribly aging brain but i kind
of think that
um in the effort to preserve it as long
as possible
uh getting enough sleep is an important
thing and i recommend it to everybody
and it's kind of like one of these
things where you can say well let me get
less sleep
you know i think only oh gosh i'm trying
to remember
how many all-nighters have i pulled in
my life i can remember
one of them when i was a teenager um
the uh um uh and um
have i pulled other ones hmm i've
certainly
uh you know i've had things where
changing time zones and flying around
the world i've had sort of somewhat
strange
sleep schedules but i think i think i've
been convinced that all-nighters don't
make a lot of sense
uh partly because what i find is if i'm
really tired
i don't think very well and i can't do
the things i want to do and it's much
better to just sleep
and then i'm actually alert and i can
figure stuff out and things happen
fairly quickly
and i can be like tired and i'm like um
i don't really know
and uh you know can't figure anything
out so i in in
in worst case i'll i'll take a um i i
one of the things that's been an
advantage of getting older is it's
getting i
i it gotten progressively easier for me
to like take a nap
for 15 minutes and have that work i
think when i was much younger
i used to have much more trouble you
know falling asleep and i i made an
active effort when i was a teenager
actually
to you know lie on one's back close
one's eyes
just fall asleep and i finally got to
the point where yes
i can really do that it's sort of a
reflex to to do that and that has the
terrible feature that
you know in all sorts of strange
situations where
uh you know i'm at a dentist's office
and i'm
you know i have to say i'm sorry you
know don't don't mind me if i fall
asleep
because when i'm in that kind of
position i sort of have this reflex of
falling asleep
but it's been a useful thing to learn
and uh something that that helps me
um okay there's uh let's take a look
here
um
let's see
um
question here from aaron ask what kind
of car do i drive
and what's the difference in technology
that fascinates me versus
technology that i just see as
utilitarian
oh interesting question i mean i've
never been a big car enthusiast
i haven't driven the car very much at
all in the past year
but um i have what do i have i have some
kind of
bmw x5 i think is the designation i
think that's right
the fact that i don't even know exactly
what kind of car i have is kind of a
sign
of a lack of profound interest i i got
this car i think
i think my wife basically picked this
car up for me and
um the uh uh i've i've generally
not been um uh and it
it sort of has the technology is okay
um and uh doesn't have anything that
sort of horribly
in your face not um um
uh kind of you know
badly designed technology i had a
previous car that was nice car to drive
but
it had just really challenged technology
um i have to say when i got this car it
was just a personal silly story but i
like
what was it a couple of two two three
years ago i'd realized i had a previous
car for 10 years
and i still didn't know how to do
certain things with that car
it had all kinds of controls and it's
like i don't really know how you get
this to work and that to work and so on
and in fact some things just didn't make
sense and you know i
i tried to figure out how do you get it
to
you know have its gps work without
having the radio on or something
and it just like you just can't do that
um and
uh so this time i got a car i decided
i would do a thing that was sort of a um
uh
a look am i gonna really read the manual
am i not gonna read the manual
and i was like okay just get the car
dealer
to spend you know an hour and show me
how the car works
and i have to say they were a little bit
surprised it seemed being asked that and
it turned out it wasn't as educational
as i hoped but it did
allow me to know oh yeah you press that
button there's this little door that
opens here and
it's like i would never have found that
i could have driven this car for a
decade and i would never have known that
so
so thanks for telling me that it was it
was a useful piece of education
but um uh i would say that um
uh sort of a big trade-off between what
technology
do you really sort of uh put effort into
understanding
what technology you just use for the
sake of using it
i tend to always try and get the kind of
most leading edge
gadgets and devices and so on unless
they just don't work very well and
there's sort of always this trade-off if
you do have things that have been well
polished
but don't don't do as much or do you
have things that do all kinds of cool
stuff but have all kinds of rough edges
and it's always a trade-off for me which
of those things i will end up
being uh you know uh dealing with and
like for example
you know that uh you know the thing i
wear on
my wrist is a you know that measures
heart rate and and motion and so on
is is not actually the very best and
latest
uh technology because the best and
latest technology
doesn't bundle in things like
uh getting text messages sent there
which
and i don't want to be wearing two
different things i mean there was a
period of time when i was wearing
a thing on one wrist a thing on a little
wrist and a thing on my ankle
um and that was like this is too too
crazy i'm not going to do this
um so you know that that's a uh that's
the trade-off there for me
but i think it's it's always um i also
tend to be somebody who
when i'm using some technological device
and i find some kind of bug with it
i make a point of actually reporting
that bug to the company that makes the
device
because i know from being on the other
side of that story people will say
oh i've been using wolfram language for
years and oh there's this really
annoying thing that happens
and you say really you know and maybe
it's a bug but maybe they just didn't
understand how to do something
but even if it's a bug it's like i wish
you'd reported that 10 years ago we
would have fixed it nine years ago then
but nobody ever reported that because
nobody ever had you know
a game pad together with uh uh you know
a zulu keyboard together with
this together with a vat and this just
never came up before but sorry
you know you've been the person who is
the one person who has that particular
combination
and so you see this
all right let's see um
it's a question here from s leia
uh asking can i explain the differences
between dc
and ac all right that's a that's a
uh he says famous last words a fairly
straightforward
sort of piece of physics and engineering
so what's that about
it's about when you're going to uh
you're going to have when you
see this is this is what always happens
the things that i think are like super
super straightforward to explain
there ends up being a little bump um
before one gets to them but okay
so this is about electrical power
and it's about how one delivers electric
power
to things so for example when you have a
power outlet
in a typical place in a typical country
uh you're plugging a
you know you plug that plug into the
wall you're getting
a certain electric current from the
electric grid
um that you can use to to power your
devices your computer whatever else
um the uh also when your computer
is connected you know you have this
adapter that goes
plugged into the wall then you plug the
other end into your computer
your the wire that's connected to your
computer is also
there's electric current going through
that wire but
the electric current that goes to your
computer is a little different than
electric current that comes out of the
uh
out of the the wall so to speak and the
difference is that
what's coming out of the wall usually is
ac or alternating current
what's going into your computer is
usually dc or direct current
okay what's what's the difference
between these the issue is
there is a voltage the voltage is kind
of what pushes electrons through wires
when you have a voltage it's like
there's a high electric potential lower
electric potential
it's like you're making a ramp and
you're forcing and the electrons go down
that ramp so when you have
when you're you're having a high a plus
voltage on one side a minus voltage on
the other side
that's defining a a potential difference
which is kind of a thing that pushes
electrons from one side to the other
and um the uh because of a vagary of the
way things have worked out you'll
actually push electrons from the minus
side to the plus side
because electrons are negatively charged
things but but that's sort of a
a detail you're you're basically pushing
uh you know
voltage is pushing electrons through
wires so direct current
is you're always pushing the same way
you just
you just push push push the electrons
through the wire and batteries for
example produce direct current there
they produce a voltage it's always
pushing in the same direction
so another thing is alternating current
and what's happening with alternating
current is
you're pushing the electrons one way for
a short time then you reverse and you
push the electrons the other way
you push them the two different ways and
for many purposes
it's perfectly sufficient to just have
electrons be pushed
for example if you're trying to heat
something up you just want electrons to
get pushed into something
the fact that they get pulled out later
pushed in pulled out
doesn't matter they they still by by
this sort of
motion of the electrons effectively
you're still heating things up doesn't
matter that you have
alternating current for other purposes
it can matter
for example if you're running a computer
it can matter that you always are
pushing the electrons the same way you
need direct current
so why is alternating current so in in
actual electrical supply in the us for
example
it's at 60 hertz which means 60 times a
second you're reversing the direction of
the voltage
and it's a it's a sine wave so it just
wiggles up and down
uh 60 times a second in some countries
like england is 50 hertz
uh some other places it's usually 50 or
60 hertz
is the typical frequency of the
electrical supply
and usually it's pretty precise actually
the there's there's a
considerable effort is often made to
arrange the the
uh the frequency to be pretty precise it
used to be the case that electric clocks
would actually uh use the uh electrical
frequency
as as the way of of um of deciding
uh of measuring time that's no longer
done it's it's just oscillation
oscillations of quartz crystals or
alternatively just data that comes from
the internet that sets time
but um but back in the day that it used
to use the frequency of electrical
supply
okay why do people use alternating
current well
the main reason is that when you're
going to
make uh you're going to send electrical
uh electricity over a long distance it
is
it uh less um
uh you you lose less power in heat
with alternating current than you do in
direct current and so
if you're going to have an and actually
it's even more than that
the higher the voltage the less you
dissipate
uh heat and so when you're sort of
taking electricity long distances when
you're for example you have a power
station
that's a hydroelectric power station
that's sitting right there at the
position of a waterfall
the um uh then you you're generating
power at the hydroelectric dam
but you want to use power at the city
that's 500 miles away
so you have to you have to have wires
that take the electricity from
hydroelectric dam to the city
and usually the the main wires are
operating at high voltage because that's
the way you lose the least
power um in transmitting so usually i
think
um 20 000 volts is common 100 000 volts
is also common
as the voltage that you're you're
sending and that's always alternating
current because
that loses less power now
back in the day there was a a big sort
of competition when
when electrical devices in the electric
grid were first getting developed
uh thomas edison and was it
george westinghouse that's right uh
westinghouse versus edison
big kind of competition of um uh who
would
uh uh who would end up being
uh you know which system would end up
being the winning system
am i am i remembering this history
correctly the um
and i think edison was not
on the right side of i'm trying to
remember
who was on which side of that story and
i remember all kinds of crazy terrible
things about
about demonstrations of electrocuting uh
poor animals with with
direct current and things and and
showing that alternating current
uh didn't work as well but it was sort
of a fake experiment and
all kinds of skull duggary but but um
having to do with with which got picked
but in the end uh for the main
electrical supply partly for this reason
of electric
of power dissipation and for other
detailed reasons of
of which technology got developed first
and so on alternating current was the
thing that got used for large-scale
supply
alternating current has to be converted
to direct current
for things like computers and that's
what that little box
that is um between the uh uh the
electric
uh supply and the computer that little
box
is uh is the thing that does the
conversion and i have to tell a little
story against myself there
that um uh many years ago as a physicist
who claimed to have invented some zero
flux transformer
that would transform alternating current
to electric current
and somebody i knew was um we really
wanted to know is this going to work
should i invest in this invention and
i'm like i don't really know
but you know this physicist is you know
is a person who does particle physics i
don't know why they would know anything
about
electric transformers and so on is a
very different design from any
transformer design that's existed up to
this point
and uh you know i kind of it's like i
don't really no i don't
i don't think it's going to work and you
know that would be my
my assumption well many years go by and
then i realized that actually
that physicist to their great credit
pushed this idea forward
and it became the standard idea that's
used in
essentially all um uh has been used
until recently there's one new idea sort
of come on the horizon
that's been used in sort of essentially
all adapters
that go from um uh for from
maine's ac mains supply
to the dc power that's used in computers
and one of the things that's actually
clever about this particular
form of adapter is it used to be the
case that if you wanted to go
from 110 volts which is in the us what
the what the voltage what the peak
voltage actually it's the
uh is that the peak or the rms um it's
the
the voltage that characterizes this
alternating current
if you want to go from the 110 volts
that is the the mains power to the
whatever it is six volts or nine volts
that you need for your computer
um that you have to pick you have one
transformer for 110 volts
if you go to england where it's 220
volts or 240 volts
um you um you need a different
transformer but this methodology for
making a transformer
allows you to have one transformer that
doesn't care what the uh what the input
voltage is
it can it can do the the transformation
of the electric current
so that's kind of the the story of um
another question of whether you can
transmit whether there are ways to
transmit direct current over long
distances
one of the things that happens is if you
could make an electrical wire
that has much lower resistivity where
the electrons you know
usually when electrons go through a wire
they keep on bumping into atoms
effectively in the wire
and they keep on being sort of not
allowed to just keep just flowing
without running into any interference so
to speak and
in superconductors they're special
materials
which are sufficiently low temperatures
the electrons can just flow
through them without effectively running
into any obstructions at all
so they have zero resistivity zero
resistance so the electrons just go
through without
without running into anything without
dissipating any heat
so the problem with superconductors is
they only exist the only ones we know
about
are ones that exist at low temperatures
so you have to have liquid nitrogen or
even liquid helium
um to cool down this uh this material
to the point where superconductivity
happens it's long been thought
one day there will be a room temperature
superconductor at which
uh sort of just in the everyday world
it'll be possible to have a
superconducting wire
if that happens the electrical grid will
be transformed i'm sure dc will be
what's used most of the time
and the electrical wires we see which
are now right now made of copper usually
um will will transform to being made of
high temperature superconductor
at which point um the the the economies
of
of uh ac versus dc will change
okay well i should probably um
uh oh there's one question here i have
to
i have to maybe address from motu if i
walk into a very powerful solenoid will
the magnetic fields affect my nervous
system
or have any other physical effect on me
that is a much debated question
so in
clearly in us humans so okay magnetic
field
if you're in a very big magnetic field
uh for example mri machines
usually use very big magnetic fields so
if you're if you're getting an mri done
and you're in the mri machine
there's usually a pretty big magnetic
field that's going through you
because that's necessary for the way
that an mri machine works
that's the m in magnetic resonance
imaging
is uh it's all about the magnetic field
so
the um uh so the question is
uh if you have a big magnetic field
going through you
does it have an effect on you if you
have a magnetic field that's rapidly
changing
is it different from having a magnetic
field that's just
a a static magnetic field that you would
get from just a big magnet
the answer is nobody really knows
there isn't the probably the most
obvious
things nothing terribly obvious happens
nothing terribly obvious goes wrong with
us humans in high magnetic fields
um but it's quite likely that there are
actually things happening so
it used to be said when i used to be
involved in particle physics uh
i used to go visit particle physics
experiments
and uh this was in days when they were a
little bit less fancy than they are
today
when they only cost a few million
dollars rather than tens of millions of
dollars but they were they would often
have these huge magnets
and physicists would say you know what
if i stand inside that magnet when it's
on
i get a funny taste in my mouth and
that's not a completely crazy thing
because the way that taste works
it involves electrochemistry and it can
involve electrical
magnetic there could be an interaction
of a magnetic field
with some of that electrochemistry i
have to say that that um
uh i have had the belief which i don't
know if it's correct
that um uh when when i pick up
a a strong magnet my fingers start
tingling
and uh my children at various times have
tried doing experiments on me to see if
it's really true
and the the results of the experiments
are are
let's say they're not they're not
definitive um but there's sort of a
question if you pick up a very heavy
magnet
and you know you have that magnetic
field particularly if you wiggle the
magnet around
can you when you have a changing
magnetic field from wiggling a magnet
around
you can induce electrical uh currents
and the question is can you induce
electrical currents in your nerves
that will cause you to like feel
tingling in your fingers just from
wiggling that magnet around
i would say that in me the the jury is
still out on whether that's
that really happens or not now if you
ask do magnetic fields have an effect on
anything in humans we're not sure about
humans
in pigeons it's pretty likely magnetic
fields have an effect
it's pretty likely that in the brains of
pigeons
there is something that detects the
magnetic field of the earth
and that's used by pigeons to as their
sort of gps-like device
to know how they navigate to to be able
to be a homing pigeon and navigate back
to
to where you were coming from and so on
and uh so it's believed that
there are devices in a pidgin's brain
that are sensitive and magnetic fields
and which presumably would be completely
scrambled
um by uh by a big magnetic field i mean
presumably if we humans have that kind
of thing
it's it's kind of like how does the
pigeon feel about its view of the world
you put the pigeon in a big magnetic
field
and you know the pigeon is going to go
you know
look around and you can have a big
debate about whether this pigeon
is having a good time or a bad time
whether it's having the time of its life
getting this big magnetic field it's
like
i'm having a great bath of magnetic
field this is wonderful
whether it's having a terrible this is
horrible i'm you know i've got this
this terrible sensation in my brain it's
hard to know because it's
it's tough to know what pigeons are
thinking but um uh whether we humans
and so the the mechanism by which uh
magnetic fields
affect uh can affect neurons in a
pigeon's brain it's not well understood
it's thought to be something to do with
it's thought to be something quite
quantum mechanical
it's thought to be something where it
has to do with
electron spins it has to do with the the
best current theory i think
is that certain chemical processes well
certain processes in biomolecules and
the molecules that
exist in proteins and things like that
that there are places
in proteins where the direction of an
electron spin
can affect the rate of certain chemical
reactions
and so what happens is when there's a
magnetic field
that causes the direction of the
electron spin to turn
and it usually electron spin doesn't
have any effect
on the rate of a chemical reaction that
the claim is in some particular cases
in for some particular proteins and
things that it can have an effect
and that that's how you can have sensory
uh
you can have a sensor that is sensitive
to magnetic fields
and you know the fact is that that one
of the things that happens is proteins
tend to pick up
all kinds of like a protein will have a
it's made of amino acids
always made of the same kind of stuff
but it can have these cages
that can enclose particular kinds of
atoms like hemoglobin
in our blood has a cage that is
specially set up to enclose an iron atom
and that's that's how we get the iron
that transports oxygen in our blood
is the hemoglobin uh protein
has this cage where as soon as you get
any reasonable amount of iron
the iron will get stuck in this cage in
in
the hemoglobin and then it can be used
to transport oxygen
and there are similar theories about
various atoms getting stuck in cages
and that's some related to the way this
magnetic field sensing works
all right i think it is time for me to
go to something
different here um so thanks for lots of
uh lots of interesting questions and i
look forward to
addressing more of them um next week and
so
um uh come back again next week and
i think next wednesday i will also be in
a live stream and we're doing those in a
two week cycle and so next wednesday is
about business and innovation
and then this time uh next week i'll be
doing another science and technology q a
so thanks for joining us and